it's actually painful for me to think
about myself like objectively
in those days
so for my long-term followers you know
that i've mentioned my own mental health
struggles a lot in passing but i still
get a ton of questions about specifics
so i thought i would do like a really
raw
story time vlog here where i could share
some of my like own disordered eating
history and then also talk about where
i'm at right now you know everything
between how i'm feeling what i'm doing
what i'm taking
and if it's working also a quick
disclaimer for those with current or
previous experiences with disordered
eating i'm definitely gonna be talking a
lot about disordered eating in this
video so as always feel free to skip
this video if it's not supportive to
your journey i'm also going to be
talking about medication and things that
i'm personally doing i am not suggesting
that anyone should be following my
regimen or taking any of the medications
or supplements that i'm taking or tried
taking
always speak to a health care provider
about your unique case and also if you
are not already subscribed hit that
subscribe button asap and also follow me
over on instagram and on tick tock at
abby's kitchen so for those of you who
don't know my full story i do give a lot
more details in my book the mindful glow
cookbook
which is right here but basically
when i was 17 i had pretty much never
dieted before i never had
insecurities about my body growing up i
know i'm really lucky and privileged to
have had that experience around 17 i
moved away from my high school friends i
was living in peterborough moved to
toronto and i basically had no friends
of course i was starting from scratch
and i had been dealing with digestive
issues then i still have ibs so nothing
really has changed there but i went to
see
a holistic naturopath who told me i was
allergic to sugar and told me i should
cut it out so i wasn't a dietitian at
the time so i didn't know any better i
just wanted to feel better so i did cut
it out and i had like this list of foods
that i was like deeming safe and that
list just started to get smaller and
smaller and smaller until i was pretty
much scared of sugar and then i was
scared of fat i was scared of all other
kind of processed foods and my body just
kept getting smaller and smaller so it
started out as classic orthorexia in
that you know my goal was never to lose
weight but i would say i have like a
classic ed mind like a classic eating
disorder mind so you know i'm type a i'm
a perfectionist people pleaser control
freak you know controlling my food
just kind of became a coping mechanism
to deal with my
general life anxiety while i never had
body insecurities or body dysmorphia
watching it shrink
and feeling somewhat in control of that
by starving myself was almost
therapeutic to me and i was really small
i'm not going to say a number because i
think that that can be really triggering
but i will say i remember
that it hurt to lay in bed sometimes
because my pelvic bones would dig into
the mattress and that was painful it's
actually painful for me to think about
myself like objectively
in those days because obviously i was
physically and emotionally hurting but i
also
didn't know or really care maybe about
what was going to happen to me as a
result of
these behaviors and looking back as a
professional now i suspect that my
eating disorder potentially played a
role in a lot of my health issues that i
have now my infertility for one and the
fact that i still to this day do not
have a proper regular menstrual cycle
and also my digestion and ibs since we
know that eating disorders can
compromise proper digestion so actually
my story is pretty common in the ibs
world so it's like you know you remove
something from the diet so that you feel
better or maybe to lose weight and it
spirals and goes too far and it gets
into disordered eating territory and
this actually can cause functional
problems with the digestive tract so it
starves the digestive organs of
nutrients and disrupts good bacteria and
it causes gastroparesis which is
basically when the stomach can't
properly contract to break down and move
food along but anyways that's a whole
other huge topic and it's very
interesting to me at least but if you
want me to do a whole video on the
intersection between
eating disorders and ibs or other
digestive disorders let me know that
would be a pretty cool video i think so
let me know if you're interested in that
now looking back i can see it was a very
bad coping strategy while i felt like at
the time that it was meant as like a
control mechanism looking back i know i
was very much not in control i'll give
you an example of how i know that so i
haven't actually talked much about my
binging i've only really talked about my
restriction i was strict so badly in the
week that on sunday nights i would allow
myself a cheat meal and in order to do
that my rule was i wasn't allowed to eat
basically all day leading up to the meal
so i would have tea chai tea and i this
taste of chai tea now still
tastes horrible to me because it brings
back so many memories the smell of chai
tea reminds me of sadness really and
then at dinner i would order all of the
highest calorie top forbidden foods
imaginable and i would like make sure
that i would finish everything on my
plate fries ribs wings nachos pasta with
cream sauce like like if it was not the
most indulgent over-the-top menu item it
wasn't worth it to me and then
despite feeling sick so full and sick i
wouldn't be done i would then have to go
out for a separate dessert and then i'd
eat like an entire slice of cake with
ice cream and all the toppings and i had
to eat it all and then the next morning
i would feel so ill i would have no
appetite basically to eat until dinner
time for whatever reason
at dinner time i would just kind of like
still be in the binge mode and i would
eat like half a cheesecake and then the
next day i would finally be able to eat
my normal restricted diet again oh it's
hard to even like revisit these memories
because i feel like i locked them up for
so long out of just
pain so maybe this is like a therapy
session i shouldn't be joking about it
but that's
what it was like you know eventually
things were getting bad and i went to
see a dietitian which was really my
first exposure to dietitians and what
dietitians do and with her help over
time i was able to kind of weight
restore but i'd say my mind was still
always thinking about calories it was
always still thinking about restricting
and kind of binging even though it
wasn't as extreme and at that point i
was kind of
at a relatively normal weight although
of course smaller than what i'm at now
but i thought it was normal enough so i
started school to become a dietitian and
it wasn't until
years later
years later when i graduated and i
finished my internship that i was just
so grossed out by the nutrition world i
didn't want to think about it anymore i
didn't want to talk about it anymore but
i kind of said [ __ ] it to my degree i
want to be a food blogger i kind of
wanted to go kind of the opposite
direction but still in the realm of food
and actually my blog was like the
catalyst to my real recovery because i
was invited to all these like different
food events and restaurant openings and
things like that and i had to decide i
had to figure out how to have a normal
balanced relationship with food
otherwise i was going to be having these
massive binge-like cheat days every
night for work or i was just gonna be
too scared to even go out to any of
these restaurants out of fear of kind of
not being in control so basically i
jumped like i just jumped all in and
somehow miraculously i had the bravery
and the courage to just kind of get it
to click for me i could have a couple
tacos at a tasting and not need to eat
every taco insight and i know i'm
oversimplifying this because there was
of course some work that had to be done
and i can go into more detail in future
videos if you want but it was kind of
surprisingly easy when i just threw
myself into that scary world of unknown
calories i think if i tried to think too
hard about it and think okay well if i'm
having a tacos for dinner then i'm gonna
have to like eat later in the in the day
no like i just had to go all in and just
say listen to your body what does it
need now and i was able to do that
because my hunger cues had been restored
from the weight restoration and from
working with a dietitian to acknowledge
that that's not always the case like if
you've been dieting for a really really
long time you're not going to have ample
diet cues you're probably not going to
be able to adequately trust your hunger
and fullness cues but when you stop
thinking about food in dichotomous terms
the novelty surprisingly wears off
pretty quickly at least that was my
experience since then i would say i've
basically had a very balanced
uncomplicated relationship with food you
know i eat treat foods on random days i
eat a variety of foods i go to dinner
and i don't make myself sick from
overeating sometimes i have all the
fatty rich foods sometimes i have a
salad so there isn't crazy hard
structure here which i know is scary as
but i guess my structure became like no
structure and somehow i just understood
that in my mind the challenge
however is that my anxiety which was
really kind of at the root of my eating
disorder that never went away i think
it's improved dramatically over the past
10 years because i've done a lot of
therapy and i've learned a lot of new
better coping mechanisms that are
actually effective and i also think that
motherhood has softened me a bit because
i don't know i think you just like have
fewer to give i do think in some ways
i've kind of just shifted my obsessive
compulsive like tendencies from one
essential area of life which is food to
another aka
sleep
so
now i have a sleep disorder and this
really took hold when e was born because
parents do you know this but postpartum
will with anyone's sleep patterns and i
think i already had some kind of deep
seated distrust in my body which then
turned into a full-blown sleep disorder
so not sleeping because you have a
newborn is one thing and it's kind of to
be expected but then not sleeping
because you're afraid of not sleeping
that's i guess a disorder and it was bad
postpartum with e but it became horrible
when i was trying to conceive oh and i
was miscarrying like most nights i was
sleeping like three to four hours and
there were some nights that i'd call
like my rock bottom nights and i
wouldn't sleep at all like not a single
minute horrible horrible horrible
horrible
memories of that time in my life like my
days were so hard and then i get to the
end of the day and you're so tired and
you just feel like oh my god i have
another marathon that i have to get
through you just were on this hamster
wheel you couldn't get off that's how i
felt and i did all the things they say
to do no screen time meditate podcast
relaxing routine you know all those like
meditation sounds and apps eventually
what would happen was i would find a
ritual that would work but then i would
become so rigid and obsessed with that
that it was almost as bad and disruptive
as just not sleeping so for example in
one phase of mine i would basically like
watch tv and fall asleep to the tv but
then if anything were off maybe a season
of the show that i was watching ended or
you know if we went to the cottage or
the room was different or i started the
routine like five or ten minutes later
because i went out for dinner i would
just get thrown off of my perfect
routine and then because i was thrown
off of the routine i wouldn't sleep at
all and then i'd switch the routine to
like this other routine so like in
another phase i switched to walking on
the treadmill but again if anything that
routine i wouldn't sleep so basically it
meant that i was trapped and my husband
was also trapped because we couldn't go
out with friends like i don't even want
him to go out alone because if he wasn't
home that would throw me off it just
felt like things were not in its place
yeah it was bad
as my therapist put it she says
everything had to be in its place for me
to sleep and that's not real life that
didn't and like it doesn't allow for me
to
live
normal life so i realized i was
basically just doing what i did with my
eating disorder but i was doing it with
my sleep like i was trying to manipulate
it and control it as a coping mechanism
for my anxiety in the process as a
result it was just kind of ruining and
running my life where am i at
today well i'm still doing lots of
therapy that's probably never going to
change and i'm constantly trying to kind
of purposefully [ __ ] with my routine
just enough that i don't get into that
ocd like obsession around sleep but i
also need to explore all of my options
for actually taking something to sleep
which i can do now because you know i'm
done breastfeeding and i'm done having
babies as far as i'm concerned right now
so first i just did herbals and
supplements like melatonin and
passionflower and magnesium and valerian
root and they would work sometimes like
i would say 50 of the time melatonin
would just like not be enough even at
really high doses which you know we
don't want to get into that so i was
needing to take ativan on top of that
you also don't want to be taking ativan
every night for the rest of your life
that is not recommended so for lots of
reasons i felt like that was just like
an unhealthy habit that i really need to
figure out how to break next i tried cbd
oil and i actually tried a whole bunch
of different ones some with thc some
without and they worked a bit just to
take the edge off but i think i'm also
kind of too far gone for that alone i'm
just a little too for the natural route
apparently
so i finally decided i was going to give
actual pharmaceutical medication a go
and i gotta say i resisted for so long
but it's been probably the best decision
i've ever made for myself and my health
i just feel like i resisted because i
didn't want to get like addicted to
something that i maybe couldn't take
while i was pregnant or nursing but like
i said i think it's safe to say that i'm
done and i'm past that phase of my life
so i can start to really focus just on
what's best for me so i'm currently
taking something called dave ego i'm not
a psychologist not a psychiatrist so
again disclaimer this is not a
suggestion to take any medications never
mind sleep medications but anyways it
was suggested to me by my doctor because
it's i guess unique in the sleep drug
world it works differently than other
sleep medications so apparently it may
be kind of less dependence forming but i
don't know i don't bank on that but
let's be real at least to me i feel like
at least psychologically any sleep
medication is gonna be somewhat
dependence forming but it has
definitely
changed my life it has changed my life
so i find that now i only have like one
to two nights a week where i have some
anxiety around sleep and i know i'm
having anxiety when i get up to pee like
10 to 12 times in the night i know it's
not because i actually have to pee it's
just because it's an anxious habit where
i become
almost like hyper aware of every
sensation in my body whether it's like a
little hunger or gotta pee or whatever
and i obsess over it even if i have like
a whisper of a thought that i have to
pee and then it's this obsession that
i've gotta get up i gotta go pee i gotta
go to bed oh i don't need to pee again i
gotta go and then i do that over and
over again and that's just like me and
my anxiety but i know it's working for
me because my sleep is just becoming
more intuitive and more natural and less
ritualistic so
sometimes i read before bed sometimes i
go right to bed and i just turn off the
light and sometimes i'll walk on the
treadmill watching a show and sometimes
i go to dinner and i have a drink like
it is so awesome
to be flexible i'm now able to gather
consistent data that i can sleep i can
do this my body's not broken that alone
i feel like helps to ease the anxiety
that i won't sleep the other thing that
i did that i feel like made a really big
difference that is like not medication
related is that i stopped setting an
alarm so if you remember from my 4 a.m
morning routine video i used to actually
get up before the kids would get up and
i would get like either a workout done
or i would answer emails get a little
bit of work done and that was generally
easy for me at the time because my body
was just so primed to get up like i just
had this energy to go even though i was
exhausted and i loved that quiet me time
i really did i also think i was scared
not to set an alarm not necessarily
because i would just sleep in but
because i was worried that if i didn't
then i would be kind of in and out of
that sleep always checking my phone
unsure of what time it was and then
thinking like should i get up should i
try to be productive should i try to
answer email should i start making
breakfast should i get a workout now
before the kids were like i was worried
about that keeping me up and i thought
maybe that would make me actually sleep
less and also i just want to say that
like skipping the workout wasn't a
rational concern for me i could be
laying in bed at night and i would be
able to rationally just tell myself yeah
you know what if you don't get up if you
don't have to exercise if you're really
tired doesn't matter you can sleep in
but then there was this like always
lingering in the back of my head in my
mind as i tried to go back to sleep in
the early morning that being like you
gotta be more productive you gotta do
more you gotta do more which of course
would make me less productive because i
wouldn't sleep and then i wasn't rested
and i'd kind of just like move through
the day like a zombie so i decided to
abolish
that morning routine abby you're not
gonna work out in the morning anymore
you're not gonna answer emails you're
not going to make breakfast until the
kids are up and they are begging you to
make the breakfast you're not even gonna
set an alarm you're gonna wait until the
kids wake you up because they are
calling for you and then you're just
gonna figure out the day does it mean
some days i don't get in as much
exercise or get as much work done in the
day maybe but not really i actually
think i'm actually more productive
because i'm just better rested so
basically by removing the pressure i
felt at night to get up early that alone
made a huge difference in my ability to
just relax and i know not everyone has
the luxury to be able to be flexible on
their schedule like that but i don't
know that has been just super helpful
for me but yeah when i shot my video on
my pei trip which you can watch right
here i mentioned that i feel that eating
disorders don't always just go away and
what i meant by that at least in my life
is that they're kind of just a temporary
band-aid for a greater bigger problem
and for me that problem is my anxiety
and it's really common for people with
addictions or mental health disorders
it's kind of just like swap disorders
once one coping mechanism loses its
effectiveness we just kind of like trade
it in for another and that's essentially
what i did in my life i don't think i've
fixed the actual problem but i feel like
medicating has definitely helped me at
least get to a better place physically i
just can't effectively manage my anxiety
when i'm sleep deprived and when my
anxiety is kind of at its lowest my
desire to control is at its lowest as
well so right now at least i feel like
this is what's working for me and i'm
just going to continue to try to like
use these drugs because they're working
for me while challenging myself outside
my comfort zone or like my safe routine
and i'll do that until i get to a place
where
i don't need these crutches anymore and
i think i'm actually getting
relatively close so i hope that was
enlightening for you guys or at least
just kind of like good to know that's
kind of where i came from and where i am
today if you like this video don't
forget to give it
that thumbs up chef's kiss
leave me a comment below if there are
other topics that you guys want to hear
me talk more about subscribe to this
channel and i will see you next time on
abby's kitchen
bye